you know our names
I'm Greg John careful what you wish for
Nick Jonas is the star of this it's a
horror movie I think what were thriller
what hey don't judge don't judge it Nick
Jonas is the only Jonas brother who
seems to have somewhat of a career after
leaving the Jonas Brothers the only one
mad respect for you I just have trouble
believing that Nick Jonas is like truly
passionate about you know starting over
well he was in scream queens you have
just enlightened me now I have more
knowledge and I'm a little more open to
then Nick Jonas I support you know when
you're a kid you don't think about
consequences a new principal but there's
something about the summer nice thumbs
that anything can happen
nice and in my case yes it did
your dad says you know a thing or two
about the sailboat
you're done right yes Venus enter
Nik bonus
stop
careful love will cost you more than you
think yeah I know what to do
taking into his own hands
even if I could take it all back
would you that's why shouldn't sleep
with married people
oh just sweet uh I guess it's not for me
like it's not made for me I like it I
think it looks like a fantastic film I
think everything about it works
from the plot set up how it might unfold
- what's his name again
don't worry undos oh no Dermot Mulroney
term oh yeah whatever I just know him as
that guy from friends once yeah I think
he's a good villain I think everything I
think Nick Jonas is a solid lead and a
blonde girl she's really not hot that's
my one problem with it
one thing this trailer really got wrong
she is not attractive but Nick Jonas
looks like a fantastic actor this looks
like a suspenseful horrifying film but
that blonde chick is the one the one
thing that couldn't get right were the
shots of her it's my honest opinion it's
my honest opinion okay
yeah okay I'm totally 100% in agreement
mm-hmm with you
we're being sarcastic I feel the exact
opposite of everything I said he's like
erotic thriller like kind of action
movies aren't made for me I think it
looks kind of silly but if you're a fan
of that thing I would rather watch this
than I can Twilight or something like
that this looks like crap this looks
like crap but it looks like Italy's be
like pulpy fun crap ah it looks like
they think they're doing a good job see
that's what I can't tell I can't tell if
this is indulging in the indulgences of
this genre but you know still keeping
the suspense up or if it is really you
know trying to be a powerful movie it
could be a genuine surprise it kind of
reminded me of that Tyler Perry movie
came out which I think was called
temptation or whatever right we saw the
trailer for that or the knows the
perfect guy yeah and then there was a
Tyler Perry one too but Beyonce I think
that's called the confession actually or
something something like that the Tyler
Perry one that was another one more I
couldn't tell like this is so over the
top and it seems to just know that so
maybe it's kind of intentionally
embracing what it is you know what would
have been cool is if this late the
blonde girl was older and not some young
hot thing I think it would have been a
much more compelling plot if she was
like then again there's a JLo movie that
just came out yeah the boy next door
yeah did of course she's gonna sleep
with Nick Jonas when she looks like
she's his age that's what I'm actually a
little confused about with this trailer
because I can't exactly tell who this is
for because the camera at least in this
trailer seems to Google her much more
than it does Nick Jonas yeah so it seems
like they really want dudes to come to
this cuz like every at least every shot
of her she's like oiled up and like in a
bikini somewhere it's clearly two dudes
fighting over I think it could be a fun
if it's if it does commit to the
r-rating like if there's actual like
real sexual content and like some real
violence then it could be enjoyable I'm
glad it's not pg-13 we'll give it that
yeah but is hope it ours an r-rating
like it earns that our rate with Isabel
Lucas and Nick Jonas in this I'm a
little I don't know if it will like I'm
[ __ ] doggystyle see ya I was like I
don't know if we'd get something like
that because I think they're gonna flirt
with the line because of Nick Jonas his
image and stuff yeah where he's like
pulling her hair and you know and she's
like faster faster and then and then she
wants ago or something and so she she
calls in his brothers it'll just there
it'll be very passionate and then like
one but inside shot I hope so
it won't be like fifty shades of gray I
hope we get a little bit of peach was
even you know Jonas really transforming
his career good for you yeah he looks
younger in this than he does when I saw
him when I said I like Nick Jonas I
think he's an entertaining guy I think
your brothers are boring but I like you
there's like a vibe I can't connect with
on him like it's somehow I don't feel
like Justin Timberlake feels like he's
really really psyched and genuine and I
feel like Nick Jonas is kind of trying
to have a career I think like when Nick
Jonas was cast in this it was a real
marketing decision like it's like hey
you're launching off on your own career
away from the Jonas Brothers okay what
can we do we get to now I'm gonna single
you will star in a teen movies so the
teens know and they want to go buy your
[ __ ] afterwards we'll put morning your
songs over the credits maybe they are
you know making something cooler than
that but it seems like that would be an
easy explanation well it's set it's in
theaters and on iTunes I will wait for
it to get an official DVD release
blu-ray yeah this foam looks great in
terms of cinematography it does why if
you're gonna see Nick Jonas as ABS Allah
you know you want to see Italy hi you
did get buff he is pretty buff good for
you Nick yeah big big bonus all right
guys we needed the channel subscribe
today
do it reject all the way John has a long
long and he likes the head out of the
bong and then eat a ding dong reasons
Jerry lot sad he's social media manager
at bloom house doom House row
follow us on our social networks I
really like my Instagram I tweet a
little more often now our face looks
pretty active J has his Instagram and
his Twitter so reasons to Jerry follow
us there because we need validation they
stuff the amount of likes we get yeah
and we want to know you a little bit I
just want the likes like this video but
like it for the right reasons
yeah because I've said